speak to retired Vice Marshall sure Bell
who has the latest and sure let's just
start with a bigger picture shall we
with Ukraine and the counter-offensive
um zielinski acknowledging publicly that
this is now underway uh tell us what
that means
you know as part of the bigger picture
yeah unfortunately there's been a
torrent of information flying around so
actually getting distilling out what the
truth is is actually quite tricky the
ukrainians are ziplit they're not
providing any information at all whereas
the Russians are on full-blown transmit
they're announcing that they are causing
huge casualties to ukrainians that
they've stopped any offensive that
they're wiping out lots of Western
kitten equipment but we'll come back
onto that wider though we've been
reporting a lot about the missile
strikes and the Drone attacks they seem
to have subsided or low car key up to
the north uh took a fair pounding and
remember the damn Nova kakovka we talked
about the waters are actually receding
quite significantly now River but the
widespread reports now from Ukraine is
that another Dam has been uh damaged by
the Russians at Nova de Vivica over by
you over there it's a much smaller Dam
and it's actually part of this whole
area of conflict almost certainly the
Russians are just trying to disrupt the
Ukrainian offensive by flooding some of
the fields so it's it's a bit less
significant than the coffee Dam and
let's just talk about what I referenced
in your introduction there Ukraine
claiming a breakthrough taking four
Villages what do we know about that yeah
the the um Ukrainian offensive at the
moment seems to be developing into two
main fronts one of which is up to the
north it's uh around back Moot and we
seem to be once again talking about Matt
mood but Ukraine trying to encircle why
that it's symbolic and therefore we're
certainly going to drag Russian forces
but um the main thing if we look at some
of the video footage we've got um these
small communities there's several of
them that have fallen they claim that
they've liberated three by the start of
the day then there was a fourth and it
looks like there's a fifth Village
that's been uh liberated as well there's
been over 25 battles over the last 24
hours and we've got these fairly grainy
footage of uh so it's very difficult to
verify at the moment
um but for the time being it what's also
interesting and away from this is that
the ukrainians now because the Nipper
river is seen as a safe haven for the
Russians they are redeploying forces so
Ukraine May well end up being able to
operate and attack amphibiously across
the donipro river again so all of these
attacks are having unintended
consequences for for the Russians as
part of this an ability to Frank and the
Russian priorities which are very
clearly now Crimea and the donbass and
it does appear that Ukrainian are making
started to make progress okay Sean
you're across it all for us we'll have
more throughout the program this
afternoon thank you for the moment